an
amendment
for
okay good morning everyone and welcome
to the stn subcommittee work session on
House Bill 609 for this
day which is October 24th I believe
correct so we'll start our meeting as
usual by asking everyone to rise and
join us in the Pledge of
Allegiance to the
flag okay thank you I want to thank the
subcommittee members for um attendance
today we have a full house and that's
good to see this is our third
subcommittee meeting on House Bill 609
we've had extensive dis discussions
about a proposed amendment and this
morning I'm hopeful that we'll be able
to reach final agreement on an amendment
to hb6 9 that we can recommend to the
full committee all members of the
subcommittee have had a copy of this
draft Amendment since last Thursday
afternoon and so they've had a chance to
digest its
contents uh and I'm looking for a
comment about whether you think the
draft we have working in front of us
here today is adequate to its purpose
represent pres ative
Harrington yeah I start with I thank you
for taking my question um I think it is
adequate and I think people need to
remember that um this may not be perfect
but it's a big step in the right
direction I've attended a couple of
meetings uh over the past few months
specifically one up the FK meeting on
the uh winter reliability program up in
Maine this summer and got to talk to a
lot of potential people that would be
building and right now New Hampshire
does not have a great reputation uh
because you know we had the Northern
Pass whether you in favor of or not a
lot of people see that as people being
against new projects there was the
latest wind project that took I don't
know six years before it finally got
licensed and that's a net of about 10
megawatt so anything we can do to
improve the process and show that we're
trying to be a little bit more efficient
I think will be received warmly by
people that might be willing to invest
whether it's transmission or energy
projects in New Hampshire and you know
if we're going to go forward with this
electrification concept we're going to
need more electricity and more
transmission to do it so something like
this that it's like I say it may not be
perfect but it's a big step in the right
direction which I think we should
take thank you for that comment I forgot
to mention that the draft in front of us
contains or reflects all of the comments
and discussions that we had at our last
subcommittee meeting so
everything that we discussed there
should have been reflected
here some of the the comments may have
been contrary to what's reflected here
but we discussed them at the time so uh
I'm I'm hopeful there's no surprises
here representative
McGee those hopes be dashed no I'm just
kidding um I I agree with uh
representative Harrington that we you
know we've been asked to do something to
try and improve the site evaluation
committee process um we did receive
input um even at the New Hampshire
energy Summit from the panel that
discussed the SEC that perhaps the
process wasn't as broken as um the ways
in which the site evaluation committee
conducted hearings so we we did have
input from folks who follow the process
um asking us if there could be some
changes made there and I think the only
thing that we've changed here as of our
last hearing that I would still question
whether it's going to meet our goal is
that we um we recanted our proposal to
make uh the adjudicative proceeding of
the sec's be something that the the
named attorney on the Public Utilities
Commission be the head of and we were
dissuaded from that by folks who
testified here but I I guess my question
would be whether we just
reconsider if that meets the purpose
that we have uh in terms of trying to to
improve the
process okay well we can have another
discussion about that so the chair of
the Public Utilities
Commission has been the chair of the
site evaluation committee since the site
EV evaluation committee was formed back
in the late
1990s it's always been that the SEC
chair was the Pu chair so we are
retaining that structure here and uh
I'd near need to hear a compelling
reason why we would need to change that
was that chair um always or only
sometimes an attorney because I know
Diane Martin was an attorney and Martin
hburg when his attorney was an attorney
so Mike can answer it I guess yeah
representative Harington the best to my
knowledge the uh chair for the most of
that time has always been an attorney
between Diane Martin and Tom getts was
very long serving on there uh Amy Nati
uh was involved and she was a lawyer as
well but the thing I think we need to
remember here is that this is a small
part of the duties of the chair of the
Pu as far as time they will have
multiple uh very formal hearings uh on
weekly monthly basis over the course of
a year where the Pu chair is going to be
running the meeting and if he's if he or
she is good enough to do that it
certainly I think it' be good enough to
do a sec hearing maybe once or twice a
year year so it's not like we're taking
someone from a department that doesn't
do adjudicative processes that's
basically all the Pu does now is a
judicate process so if they're qualified
to be the chair of the Pu and do that on
a daily basis they're certainly
qualified to do it as far as chair of
the SEC on a maybe two or three time a
year
basis any further comment on this
question okay seeing none any further
comments on the proposed uh
Amendment all right I'd like to hear
your uh thoughts about whether we as a
subcommittee would be willing to vote to
recommend to the full committee the
adoption of this
amendment representative Corman thank
you Mr chairman yeah I I I feel like
we've gone through this quite a bit uh
it's as representative Harrington said
I'm agreeing with him again it's not
perfect perfect but it's it's a good
step in the right direction um and I am
prepared to
vote speaking of that representative
Corman and Harrington agreeing with one
another I think representative
Harrington said after the meeting our
last subcommittee meeting that the two
of you agreeing with each other would
probably mean that the Patriots would
win the following weekend so we have
another chance this week coming
up so that turned out to be a preent
prediction on your part okay a further
comment on whether we or not we should
recommend to the full committee the
adoption of this
amendment representative
Kaplan yeah I I agree with the uh the
other Representatives on this
subcommittee uh that uh I'm ready to
vote I think it does the purpose that we
set out to uh to meet which is to
streamline the process that does that
and also Al at the same time safeguards
the public interest I believe
sufficiently and and uh as people as
representative Harrington said uh the
proof will be in the pudding so uh no no
no process is perfect but uh we need to
let this vessel sail and see how it see
how it
does and I'll remind everybody on the
subcommittee that even if we recommend
this amendment to the full committee the
full committee will still debate it and
decide its fate and if it should go
forward to the Full House
there'll be another debate there and
then if it gets past the house it'll go
to the Senate there'll be another debate
there so there's plenty of other
opportunities for further tweaks in this
uh in this amendment well given the the
sense of the committee then I will make
the motion that the
subcommittee uh recommend to the full St
the adoption of the text of this
proposed amendment I will submit this
text to OLS later today and ask that it
be formalized into an amendment and we
will propose that to the full committee
at exec session on
November on November 6th at 10:00
a.m. is there a second to the motion
then okay it's moved in seconded let's
have a vote uh all those in favor say I
I I I any
opposed excellent so our subcommittee
work I believe is is done I want to
thank you for being here sorry it was
such a short meeting but uh short
meetings can be good at times right so
thank you everyone for attending and
uh stay tuned for further information
about all this at exec session on
November the 6th thank
you